I went to Scotland last October and had
this like life-changing trip I wasn't
playing the old course but I was in St
Andrews and I was alone and and just
showed up I I you know hired a caddy and
she was like all right you ready and
then I I didn't even have time to warm
up and I'm on Jubilee and it's one of
the windiest days of the year and I was
like I don't know if I can do this I
don't know what I'm doing and he was
just like oh just hit the damn ball and
I was like okay and sometimes you just
got to hit the damn ball yeah might not
go straight it might but just hit the H
hit the damn ball so sometimes you just
got to get out there and hit the damn
ball you heard her hit the damn ball
folks or just take a swing even if you
don't hit it you swung yeah pick up the
club just pick up the club yeah